Lucia: hmm hmm hmm
Lucia: even i stay
Lucia: even I stay
Lucia: hmm hmm hmm
Shure: 四个一次
Shure: Four at once.
Shure: 四个两次
Shure: Four twice.
Shure: 4个三次so成交
Shure: Four three times, so it's a deal!
Shure: 然后大家拿到手可以其实用
Shure: Then you can actually use what you get.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Lucia: 这个如果大家一会有人喜欢
Lucia: If anyone likes this later...
Lucia: 也可以拍拍试试
Lucia: You can give it a try.
Lucia: 就这个也
Lucia: This...
Lucia: 其实也是压花
Shure: 要不你拿着给大家展示一下
Shure: Why don't you hold it up and show everyone?
Shure: 呃我拿着来
Shure: Uh, I'll hold it up.
Shure: 还是给大家展示一下吧
Shure: Let's just show everyone.
Shure: 这个会看的更
Shure: This way, it'll be more clear.
Lucia: 哎我把手机放哪了在这
Lucia: Hey, where did I put my phone? Oh, here it is.
Shure: 更那什么一点对
Shure: ...more like that, right.
Lucia: 哦在这底下
Lucia: Oh, it's under here.
Shure: 给大家看一下
Shure: Let me show everyone.
Lucia: 没事没事，谢谢
Lucia: 嗨这是什么呀
Lucia: Hey, what's this?
其他人：有有有白手套吗
Others: Do we have any white gloves?
其他人：给你上一套
Others: Here, let me give you a pair.
Shure: 然后还有啊
Shure: And then, there's also...
其他人：你这个不专业啊
Others: You're not very professional with this.
Shure: 还有这个
Shure: And there's this.
Katrina: 怎么进上来的
Katrina: How did you get in here?
Shure: 这个是一个楼的
Shure: This is from the same building.
Shure: 还有这两个
Shure: And these two as well.
Lucia: 为什么你开了手电筒可是他却没开
Lucia: Why did you turn on the flashlight, but he didn't?
Shure: 对纯景的
Shure: Yeah, it's for the scenery.
Lucia: 快没电了吗
Lucia: Is it running out of battery?
其他人：因为有人的不太好
Others: Because some people's lights aren't that good.
Lucia: 哎也不是
Lucia: Well, not really.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: 那就先先拍一个楼的吧好吧
Shure: Let's just take a picture of the building first, alright?
Lucia: 哎好奇怪
Lucia: So strange.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 他可能BUG了
Lucia: Maybe it's bugged.
Lucia: 我来开一下
Lucia: Let me try turning it on.
Shure: 这个楼的啊对
Shure: This building, yeah.
Shure: 一个大摩呃
Shure: A big skyscraper, uh...
Lucia: 我这边好像好着
Lucia: It seems fine on my side.
Shure: 也不算摩天吧
Shure: Not exactly a skyscraper.
Lucia: 为什么
Lucia: Why?
景井
Scenery Well
Shure: 起拍价还是一个一个
Shure: The starting bid is still one by one.
Lucia: 看不懂两个
Lucia: I can't understand these two.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure: 两个
Shure: Two.
Shure: 两个一次
Shure: Going twice for two.
其他人：哄抬一下特价啊
Others: Let's inflate the price a bit, huh?
其他人：三个
Others: Three.
Shure: 两个两次
Shure: Two, going twice.
Shure: 你怎么都要买过来吗
Shure: Are you really going to buy it?
Lucia: 所以所以这是怎么样
Lucia: So, so how does this work?
Lucia: 用用手电筒照可以看到呢
Lucia: Can you see it if you shine a flashlight on it?
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 三个三个一次
Shure: Three times, all at once.
Katrina: 他是黑白胶片你照了才照的开
Katrina: It's black and white film, you need to shine the light for it to appear.
Lucia: 哦这么神奇
Lucia: Oh, that's amazing.
Shure: 三个两次
Shure: Three, twice.
Shure: 三个三次
Shure: Three, three times.
Shure: 成交
Shure: Deal.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Shure: 还有最后一个
Shure: There's one more.
Shure: 这个是一个海的啊对
Shure: This one's about the sea, right.
Shure: 它是个海的
Shure: It's about the sea.
Shure: 起拍价还是一个
Tasha: 不是为什么有人吃了给我一个
Tasha: Why did someone eat it and give me one?
Shure: 一个
Shure: One.
其他人：一个
Others: One.
Shure: 有人一个
Shure: Someone, one.
其他人： 两个
Others: Two.
其他人：两个
Jake: 给给他钱吧
Jake: Give him the money.
Shure: 两个两个一次
Shure: Two, two at once.
其他人：她三个
Others: She got three.
Shure: 你就不要不要跟gas抢了好吗
Shure: Don't compete with gas, okay?
Shure: 2个两次
Shure: Two, twice.
其他人：三个
Others: Three.
Shure: 3个一次
Shure: Three, once.
其他人：我也试吃一下回口比较好我一会儿帮你卖一下
Others: Let me taste it, I'll help you sell it later.
Shure: 3个3个
Shure: Three, three.
Shure: 3个一次啊
Shure: Three, once.
Shure: 三个两次
Shure: Three, twice.
其他人：对我已经体验过了
Others: Yeah, I've already experienced it.
Shure: 没事咱们咱们可以说着
Shure: No worries, we can talk about it.
Shure: 四个四个一次
Shure: Four, four at once.
其他人：我还没叫
Others: I haven't called yet.
其他人：行四个四个
Others: Okay, four, four.
Shure: 四个两次
Shure: Four, twice.
其他人：快点快点快点
Others: Hurry, hurry, hurry.
Shure: 四个三次成交
Shure: Four deals, three times.
其他人：我要马上就要哈哈哈
Others: I need it right now, hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：太急迫了马上必须 马上把钱给我
Others: Too urgent, give me the money right now
Shure: OK变成大富翁了
Shure: OK, I'm becoming a tycoon
Shure: 富婆饿饿饭饭
Shure: Rich lady needs food
Tasha: 要不是要不是替你还债了
Tasha: If it weren't for paying off your debt
Shure: 好的然后
Shure: Alright then
Shure: 现在谁手上的比较少一点
Shure: Who has the least in hand right now?
其他人：我
Others: Me
其他人：8+8-4，12个
Lucia: 点
Lucia: Point
Shure: 还有12个你呢
Shure: You still have 12, how about you?
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my
Shure: 6个
Shure: 6 pieces
Tasha: 我就自我介绍
Tasha: I'll just introduce myself
Tasha: 没有用啊
Tasha: It's useless though
Shure: 那黄导你先上来介绍一下你的拍品吧
Shure: Nicous, come up and introduce your auction item
Shure: 是中间这个相机吗
Shure: Is it this camera in the middle?
其他人：这玩意我看看
Others: Let me take a look at this thing
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake: 你要要这相机我们直接起飞
Jake: If you want this camera, we can take off right away
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Jake: ego币
Jake: Ego coin
Shure: 哈来吧来吧
Shure: Haha, come on, come on
Shure: 黄岛黄岛先生
Shure: Mr. Nicous
其他人： 不幸的问题是我今天还真没有什么拍品
Others: The unfortunate thing is I really don't have any auction items today
其他人： LUCIA 好像完全忘记跟我说这个事儿
Others: Lucia totally forgot to tell me about this
Lucia: 我好像没跟他说这个事这个样子了呢
Lucia: Seems like I didn't tell him about this, my bad
Alice: 讲个故事
Alice: Tell a story
Alice: 哎不对这是拍卖会
Alice: Oh wait, this is an auction
Lucia: 我因为我自己因为我自己忘了
Lucia: I forgot, I totally forgot
Lucia: 你你你不是还有瓶水吗
Lucia: Don't you still have a bottle of water?
Lucia: 哈哈哈你不是还有瓶水吗
Lucia: Haha, don't you still have a bottle of water?
其他人：哦非常实用啊 实用道具
Others: Oh, very practical, a useful item
Jake: 完了和和市场接轨了现在
Jake: Now it's in line with the market
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
Shure: 他这有一瓶我们这都没有的饮料
Shure: He has a drink that we don't have here
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人： 市场化道具
Others: Marketized item
Shure: 起拍价一个
Shure: Starting bid is one.
Shure: 没有没有那个
Shure: No, no, not that one.
Jake: 你后面的是不是
Jake: Is the one behind you?
Shure: 我我靠
Shure: Me? Oh, damn.
Shure: 这也是你的
Shure: This is also yours.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 这是我的
Tasha: This is mine.
Shure: 要不这样吧
Shure: How about this?
Shure: 那个给大家一起我们拍一组照片
Shure: Let's all take a group photo together.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then...
Lucia: 啊这个他擅长哈哈哈
Lucia: Ah, he's good at this. Hahaha.
Shure: 也算是卖了一波艺
Shure: It's like selling a bit of art.
Shure: 怎么怎么拍
Shure: How do we take it?
Shure: 你可以定时下或者是怎么着
Shure: You can set a timer or something.
其他人：拍到了给他们拍一组写真
Others: Take a set of photos for them.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Tasha: 我靠还可以还真
Tasha: Damn, that's pretty cool.
Jake: 灯灯灭了
Jake: The lights went out.
Katrina: 我吗我在冲啊
Katrina: Me? I'm rushing.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
其他人：嗯大家稍微聚拢一点吧
Others: Yeah, everyone gather a bit.
Jake: 可能是吧
Jake: Maybe.
Jake: 看一下吧
Jake: Let's take a look.
Jake: 没有就算了
Jake: If not, forget it.
Lucia: 没有就
Lucia: If not, then...
Jake: 看一下看一下
Jake: Let's check it out.
Tasha: 是这样子的呢
Tasha: Is it like this?
Tasha: 耶哈哈
Tasha: Yay, haha.
其他人： 后面的背景会有些黑看见光了
Others: The background will be a bit dark. There's some light.
Lucia: 好有点有点背光
Lucia: Yeah, it's a bit backlit.
其他人： 哦逆光
Others: Oh, it's backlit.
其他人： 还是到我们这边来
Others: Better come over to our side.
其他人：我把饮料搁这
Others: I'll put the drink here.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia: 都站到那个椅子的前面去吗还是
Lucia: Should we all stand in front of the chair, or...
其他人：啊你往后推就行
Others: Just push it back.
其他人： 那要不把椅子调个吧 因为前面有些坐着比较好
Others: Or move the chair, it's better to sit in front.
Lucia: 哦对对要不然话大家可能就会
Lucia: Oh, yeah, otherwise everyone might...
Jake: 哼
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 老板
Jake: Boss
Lucia: 有人坐着有人
Lucia: Some people are sitting, some people...
Jake: 帮我调第一个
Jake: Help me adjust the first one.
其他人： 那我们往后
Others: Then we'll move back.
其他人：坐着还坐到这儿
Others: Sitting here again.
Lucia: 我站着 Gast风格
Lucia: I'm standing, Gast style.
Lucia: 啊对 Gast可以坐
Lucia: Ah right, Gast can sit.
Jake: Gast先坐行吗
Jake: Gast, you sit first, okay?
其他人： 之前都谁坐了先坐吧 还坐着
Others: Whoever sat before, just sit again. Still sitting.
Jake:Gast先坐
Jake: Gast, you sit first.
Jake: 然后就是志愿者往后坐
Jake: Then the volunteers move back.
Jake: Gaster先往前坐
Jake: Gaster, move up front.
Jake: Gaster往前坐
Shure: 纯黑的哦
Shure: Completely black, huh.
其他人：其实只有第二排能拍到 是吧
Others: Actually, only the second row can be filmed, right?
Tasha: 然后空白的对
Tasha: And then the blank part, right.
Jake: 哦那前面三个椅子干掉是吧
Jake: Oh, so we get rid of the first three chairs, right?
Jake: 挪掉
Jake: Move them away.
Shure: 来吧老板
Shure: Come on, boss.
Lucia: 拍照环节合影环节
Lucia: Photo session, group photo session.
Jake: 哎请坐请坐
Jake: Hey, please sit down, please sit down.
Shure: 你本来最高
Shure: You were already the tallest.
Shure: 然后就还给自己加磅是吧
Shure: And then you added more weight, right?
Jake: 哎请坐请坐
Jake: Hey, please sit down, please sit down.
Alice: 坐刘婷
Alice: Sit down, Liu Ting.
Jake: 请坐请坐
Jake: Please sit down, please sit down.
Shure: 呀真好看
Shure: Wow, you look great.
Jake: 请坐请坐
Jake: Please sit down, please sit down.
Alice: 坐
Alice: Sit down.
Lucia: 耶你怎么这么高
Lucia: Yeah, why are you so tall?
其他人： 怎么都没人坐啊
Others: Why is no one sitting?
Jake: 请坐请坐
Jake: Please sit down, please sit down.
Jake: 三位客人请坐
Jake: Three guests, please sit.
其他人：坐前面坐着
Others: Sit in the front.
其他人：后面有人站着
Others: There's someone standing at the back.
其他人：不觉得像这种家族照片
Others: Doesn't it feel like a family photo?
其他人：像那个什么
Others: Like that, what...
Lucia: 哈哈哈家族照一样
Lucia: Haha, like a family photo.
Shure: 老板老板老板来来来
Shure: Boss, boss, boss, come on, come on.
Katrina: 老板坐中间
Katrina: Boss, sit in the middle.
Jake: 老板老板老板
Jake: Boss, boss, boss.
Shure: 老板站中间老板站中间
Shure: Boss, stand in the middle. Boss, stand in the middle.
Jake: 站后面站旁边就好了
Jake: Just stand at the back or the side, it's fine.
其他人：你也得过来
Others: You need to come over too.
Lucia: 福星你这个相机有自动那个什么吗
Lucia: Fuxing, does your camera have auto-something?
Jake: 有
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 呃是可以的
Lucia: Uh, that's fine then.
Jake: 有三脚架
Jake: There's a tripod.
Lucia: 但是有三脚架
Lucia: But there's a tripod.
Jake: 有三脚架
Jake: There's a tripod.
Lucia: 有三脚架有三脚架子
Jake: 对我们三脚架子多了
Jake: Yeah, we have plenty of tripods.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎现在可以哦
Lucia: Hey, it's working now.
Lucia: 不可以你是没那个啥了
Lucia: No, it can't, you don't have that thing.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
其他人：我刚刚在说家族照
Others: I was just talking about a family photo.
其他人：专业设备
Others: Professional equipment.
其他人：这三脚架一直没用上
Others: This tripod hasn't been used.
其他人：没用上哈哈就等你呢
Others: Haven't used it, haha, just waiting for you.
Shure: 哈哈哈就等你呢
Shure: Haha, just waiting for you.
Jake: 对就等你了
Jake: Yeah, just waiting for you.
Shure: 我们算到了其实
Shure: We actually figured it out.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
其他人：那狗的CP呢
Others: What about the dog's partner?
Alice: 我我我我狗的老老婆呢
Alice: Me, me, me, where's my dog's old wife?
Lucia: 那里
Lucia: Over there.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 在这蹲俩是吧
Jake: Squatting here, right?
Lucia: 哎可以让他们加进来可以吗
Lucia: Hey, can we let them join?
Jake: 猜不到吧
Jake: You can't guess, right?
Lucia: 他俩在前面哎
Lucia: They're in front, hey.
其他人： 对让他俩前东西吧
Others: Yeah, let them be in front.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 这边
Jake: Over here
Lucia: 要不咱俩换一下那个啥
Lucia: How about we switch places?
Lucia: 因为
Lucia: Because...
Katrina: 要不我站边上你站他俩中间
Katrina: How about I stand to the side and you stand between them?
Lucia: 这样可以在
Lucia: That way we can...
其他人：你想过来就来吧
Others: If you want to come over, just come over.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's fine.
其他人：你别太矜持了你
Others: Don't be so reserved.
Lucia: 哈哈你在这边
Lucia: Hahaha, you stay over here.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice: 我打不着你了是吧
Alice: I can't reach you, can I?
Lucia: 然后我们可以这样
Lucia: Then we can do this...
Alice:见证见证一对
Alice: Witness, witness a pair...
其他人：哈哈一对新人
Others: Haha, a pair of newlyweds.
Lucia: 一对新人一对新
Lucia: A pair of newlyweds, a pair of...
Lucia: 狗哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Dogs, hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 你的狗戴花花
Lucia: Your dog wears flowers.
Lucia: 你的狗才是新娘
Lucia: Your dog is the bride.
Lucia: 哈哈哈你的狗笑你
Lucia: Hahaha, your dog is laughing at you.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：说的我脸红了
Others: You're making me blush.
Alice: 感谢你特别邀请
Alice: Thanks for the special invitation.
Katrina: 他也他也红了哈哈
Katrina: He's blushing too, haha.
Jake: 然后你看怎么搞的
Jake: So how are you going to do this?
Jake: 它是有一个
Jake: It's got a...
其他人：确实这个看起来比较像新郎
Others: Indeed, this one looks more like the groom.
Jake: 行行没问题
Jake: Okay, okay, no problem.
其他人：可以吻新娘
Others: You may kiss the bride.
Tasha: 哦对对对
Tasha: Oh, right, right.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈救命
Lucia: Hahaha, help me!
Jake: 后面没
Jake: Is there more?
Alice: 祸乱后宫罪不容诛
Alice: Stirring up the harem, unforgivable!
Jake:是一页吗
Jake: Is it one page?
Shure: 就就放这些吧
Shure: Just put these here.
Shure: 那个放白的那个有点就是照到脸上了
Shure: The white one is kind of shining on the face.
Jake:OK行行行
Jake: OK, okay, okay.
Lucia: 咱这甚至还有补光灯呢
Lucia: We even have fill lights here.
Lucia: 不需哈哈
Lucia: No need, haha
其他人：可以啊哎呦
Others: Sure, oh wow
其他人：补光灯啊
Others: It's the fill light
Jake: 补光灯要到前面的
Jake: The fill light needs to be in the front
其他人：暂时不用了
Others: We don't need it for now
Jake: 还不用啊
Jake: Not yet?
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay
Alice: 来吧
Alice: Let's go
其他人：呃好
Others: Uh, okay
Jake: 雨萱拿
Jake: Yuxuan, take it
Jake: 可以拿一个眼镜
Jake: You can take a pair of glasses
Jake: 你可以不戴
Jake: You don't have to wear them
Katrina: 那我假装带上
Katrina: Then I'll pretend to put them on
Jake: 你也可以
Jake: You can too
其他人：好 10秒自拍模式啊
Others: Okay, 10-second selfie mode, huh
其他人：启动好
Others: Ready, go
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Everyone:
Shure: 这一幕好像好似曾相识
Shure: This scene feels so familiar
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay
Alice: OK
Shure: 来吧我觉得这波的才艺
Shure: Come on, I think this round's talent show
Jake:很有才艺
Jake: Is very talented
Shure: 123456
Jake: 黄一波
Jake: Huang Yibo
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good
Shure: 6吧
Shure: Yeah
Shure: 再来俩 8个发发发
Shure: Let's do two more, 8 total, let's go
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：凳子把凳子再搬回去呗
Others: Move the chairs back again
其他人：都是谁对应的
Others: Who's responsible for which
其他人：凳子好
Others: Chairs, alright
其他人：再拿回去
Others: Take them back
Alice: Lucia
其他人：真漂亮
Others: Really beautiful
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Lucia: 嘿嘿我已经带上了
Lucia: Hehe, I already put them on
Shure: 大家搬搬下凳子
Shure: Everyone, move the chairs
Shure: 然后回到原位
Shure: And return to your places
Shure: 然后我们继续进行这个拍卖环节
Shure: Alright, let's continue with the auction segment.
Tasha: 还有谁
Tasha: Who else?
Shure: 谢宾主呢
Shure: Thanks to the host.
Shure: 谢宾主点
Shure: Thanks to the host for the point.
Katrina: 先点吧
Katrina: Just go ahead.
Shure: 谢宾主
Shure: Thanks to the host.
其他人：点什么呀
Others: What's the point?
Jake: 披萨大披萨超级大披萨
Jake: Pizza, big pizza, super big pizza.
Shure: 7民主
Shure: 7 democracy.
Alice: 干嘛老公动手动脚的
Alice: Why are you touching me, honey?
Alice: 大庭广众
Alice: In front of everyone.
其他人：你穿点衣服吧你
其他人：我的我的我的
Others: Mine, mine, mine.
Alice: 刘婷你的够花吗
Alice: Liu Ting, do you have enough?
Alice: 要不我给你偷俩
Alice: Should I steal a couple for you?
Katrina: 哈哈你对人太好了
Katrina: Haha, you're too kind to people.
其他人：投俩币我去投俩
Others: Throw in two coins, I'll throw in two.
Alice: 我去偷俩
Alice: I'll steal two.
其他人：这不是假钞吗
Others: Isn't this fake money?
Lucia: 你在check吗
Lucia: Are you checking?
Lucia: 让我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Tasha: 你买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy it?
其他人：嗯还不错哦
Others: Yeah, not bad.
Tasha: 还没买那你就想点跑腿
Tasha: You haven't bought it, and you want to order delivery?
Lucia: 哎好看哎这个
Lucia: Oh, this looks good.
其他人：大家状态都很不错人际线也挺好的
Others: Everyone's doing well, the vibe is good.
Lucia: 不错不错
Lucia: Not bad, not bad.
Lucia: 预热这个
Lucia: Warm up this.
其他人：哈哈对挺好
Others: Haha, yeah, it's good.
其他人：黑的是什么
Others: What's the black thing?
Katrina: 对这这是什么
Katrina: Yeah, what is this?
Katrina: 这是那个
Katrina: It's that thing.
Lucia: 那个那个灯
Lucia: That light.
其他人：嗯挺好的
Others: Yeah, it's pretty good.
其他人：状态都很不错的哎
Others: Everyone's in good shape, huh?
Lucia: 谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Thanks, thanks.
其他人：状态都很不错
Others: Everyone's in good shape.
Lucia: 棒棒感谢哈哈
Lucia: Awesome, thanks, haha.
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What?
Lucia: 哎我又踩到自己裙子了
Shure: 了盖上盖上盖
Shure: Yeah, cover it, cover it.
其他人：修硕
Others: Shure.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 就是那最大最大的那个
Shure: It's the biggest one, the biggest.
Shure: 点
Shure: Press it.
Lucia: 啊那我得坚持10秒吗
Lucia: Ah, do I need to hold for 10 seconds?
Shure: 先点一个
Shure: Press one first.
Shure: 然后再点点别的吧
Shure: Then press the others.
Lucia: 好久哦表情都不自然了
Lucia: It's taking so long, my expression is unnatural.
其他人：看看你的表情还不自然
Others: Look, your expression is still unnatural.
Shure: 点
Shure: Press it.
Lucia: 你看后面又过坡了哈哈
Lucia: Look, there's another slope behind, haha.
其他人：没有
Others: No, there's not.
Shure: 点了点了
Shure: Pressed, pressed.
Alice: Lucia我想跟你合照一张
Alice: Lucia, I want to take a picture with you.
Lucia: 哎还可以好呀
Lucia: Oh sure, we can do that.
Lucia: 只要有福星出现的地方
Lucia: Anywhere there's a lucky star...
Lucia: 他就会变成摄影师
Lucia: He becomes the photographer.
Alice: 真好啊
Alice: That's great.
Shure: 你增加点囤货吗
Shure: Are you stocking up on supplies?
Tasha: 怎么可能没有
Tasha: How could there not be?
Lucia: sorry sorry sorry my fault
Lucia: Sorry, sorry, sorry, my fault.
Lucia: 要不要把它转一下打到脸上
Lucia: Do you want to turn it and hit your face?
Lucia: 哈哈可以
Lucia: Haha, you can.
Lucia: 我们站这边的话可以调
Lucia: If we stand here, we can adjust it.
Lucia: 其实可以调一下
Lucia: Actually, we can adjust it.
Lucia: 让它给脸上补点光之类的
Lucia: Let it shine a bit more light on our faces.
Alice: 那我们站这里
Alice: Then we'll stand here.
Alice: 差不多
Alice: Almost there.
Lucia: 对对可以
Lucia: Yes, yes, that's good.
Lucia: 抱住
Lucia: Hold it.
Lucia: 我眼睛好像有点往下滑
Lucia: My eyes seem to be slipping down a bit.
Lucia: 我这个镜框稍有点大
Lucia: My glasses frame is a bit big.
Lucia: 所以汤老师
Lucia: So Mr. Tang...
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎可以好看
Lucia: Oh, it looks good.
Alice: 谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
其他人：咱俩合格影呗
Others: Let's take a picture together.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Alice: 我我我不太会拍哦
Alice: I'm not very good at taking pictures.
Alice: 你就说什么
Alice: What are you saying?
Lucia: 他这个相机很
Lucia: This camera is really...
Lucia: 这这这还是你之前的相机吗
Lucia: Is this still your old camera?
Lucia: 你有升级设备吗
Lucia: Did you upgrade your equipment?
其他人：没什么变化
Others: Not much change.
Alice: 这可以打鸟吗
Alice: Can this shoot birds?
其他人：呃那再换镜头
Others: Uh, then change the lens.
其他人：带了，其实有
Lucia: 哇你怎么带这么齐装备
Lucia: Wow, how did you bring so much gear?
Alice: 我是点这个就可以，是吗
其他人：对这个
Shure: 我们
其他人：没关系
Others: It's okay.
其他人：拍不出去也没关系的
Others: It's fine if it doesn't turn out well.
Alice: 这是拍上了吗
Alice: Did it capture it?
Alice: 是不是有点太近了
Alice: Isn't it a bit too close?
其他人：是的没事
Others: Yes, it's fine.
其他人：待会再说吧
Alice: 好谢谢
Alice: Okay, thanks.
Shure: 来吧现在我们下一位拍卖者
Shure: Alright, now our next auctioneer.
Shure: 啊来吧
Shure: Ah, come on.
其他人： 本次拍卖的东西主要是有两个
Others: There are mainly two items in this auction.
其他人：这个呢是一盒可孚 的牙线棒
Others: This is a box of Kefu dental floss sticks.
其他人： 为什么要选择这个呢 主要是因为有一句老话叫什么叫
Others: Why choose this? Mainly because there's an old saying, what is it...
Alice: 叫啥呀
Alice: What is it?
其他人：叫啥叫什么
Others: What is it, what is it called...
其他人：叫一句老话
Others: It's an old saying.
其他人：等一下哈哈哈哈
Others: Wait a minute, hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人：不会是沃斯蒂说的
Others: Could it be Wosti who said it?
其他人： 啊麦斯尔夫说的
Others: Ah, it was said by Maiself.
Alice:哈哈哈呃
Alice: Hahaha, uh...
其他人： 说一句是牙齿疼不是病疼起家真要命啊这句话
Lucia: 才真要问出来一句话
Lucia: Just had to ask.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
其他人：你确定这话是麦瑟尔夫说的吗
Others: Are you sure it was Maiself who said it?
其他人： 啊对麦斯尔夫说的
Others: Ah, yes, it was Maiself.
其他人：所以呢对这个
Others: So, about this...
其他人：对牙齿健康口腔健康 对我们来额外的重要
Other: Dental and oral health are extra important to us.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
其他人：所以这就是作为我们的第一件拍卖品
Other: So, this will be our first auction item.
其他人： 我们从 一个币开始拍
Other: We'll start the bidding at one coin.
其他人：一个OK
Other: One coin, okay.
其他人： 一个
Other: One.
其他人： OK
Other: Okay.
其他人：哈哈哈啊
Other: Hahaha.
其他人： 一个币一个币还有吗
Other: One coin, one coin, any more?
其他人：什么招手5个币是吗
Other: What, waving for 5 coins, right?
Alice:哈哈哈招手5个币
Alice: Hahaha, waving for 5 coins.
其他人：一个币一个币一次
Other: One coin, one coin, going once.
其他人：一个币两次
Other: One coin, going twice.
Shure: 一个币两次
Shure: One coin, going twice.
其他人：三个币是吧
Other: Three coins, right?
Alice: 我都没有我跟你讲
Alice: I don't have any, I'm telling you.
其他人： OK一个币三次恭喜你
Other: Okay, one coin, going three times. Congrats!
其他人： 太好了
Other: Great!
其他人：内部消化了
Other: Handled internally.
其他人：啊对
Other: Oh, right.
其他人：照片给我
Other: Give me the photo.
其他人：哈哈哈就当就当是他拍的
Other: Hahaha, let's pretend he won it.
其他人：因为他那个小狗没跟我收钱
Other: Because he didn't charge me for the puppy.
Shure: 亲兄弟明算账是吧
Shure: Fair and square, right?
Alice: 在身无分币的年纪遇见了最想要的啥
Alice: In the days of having no money, I found what I wanted the most.
Alice: 牙线棒是吗哈哈哈
Alice: Dental floss picks, right? Hahaha.
其他人： OKOK接下来 是我们第二个拍品是一本书叫 月亮河6
Other: Okay, okay. Next up is our second auction item, a book called "Moon River 6".
其他人： 不会是盗版书吧
Other: It's not a pirated book, right?
Shure: 盗版书
Shure: A pirated book.
其他人：不能吧我看一下
Other: No way, let me check.
Alice: 你从哪偷的你跟我说说
Alice: Where did you steal it from, tell me.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 这没有
Tasha: There's nothing.
其他人：OKOK就是 有这么一本书啊 俗话说的好
Other: Okay, okay. There's this book, as the saying goes...
其他人： 这个书籍是人类进步的阶梯 这个应该不是我说的
Other: Books are the ladder of human progress. I didn't say this.
其他人： 那么我们是的是的那
Other: So, we... yes, yes...
Shure: 这是高尔基说的
Shure: That's what Gorky said.
其他人： 那我们这个第二件拍卖品起步价一个币
Other: So, the starting bid for this second auction item is one coin.
其他人：一个币哈哈哈
Other: One coin, hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahahahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha
其他人：一个币一次
Others: One coin per turn
Shure: 这绝版的这书都
Shure: This book is rare
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha
其他人：这可是月亮河 哈哈哈
Others: This is Moon River, hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Shure: 我看看这到底是谁
Shure: Let me see who it is
其他人： 可能就是译文有问题应该是原版
Others: Maybe it's a translation issue, it should be the original
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
其他人： 应该是一个看起来很像盗版正版书
Others: It looks like a pirated version of the original book
其他人：满地都是月亮他却抬头看到6便士
Others: The ground is full of moonlight, yet he looks up and sees sixpence
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha
其他人： 一个币两次
Others: Two coins per turn
Shure: 2个币
Shure: Two coins
其他人：OK两个币一次
Others: OK, two coins per turn
其他人： 这么胜券再握书都给我拿走了
其他人：两个币两次哦
Others: Two coins per turn, okay?
Shure: 谢斌竹出3个币
Shure: Xie Binzhu bids three coins
其他人：什么什么
Others: What?
Shure: 谢斌竹出3个币
Shure: Xie Binzhu bids three coins
Tasha: 他出3个币
Tasha: He bids three coins
其他人： OK三个币 一次
Others: OK, three coins, going once
其他人：这个错版书错版书三个币两次
Others: This misprinted book, three coins, going twice
其他人：OK三个币三次成交
Others: OK, three coins, sold!
其他人：谢云竹拿钱
Others: Xie Yunzhu, pay up
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 银行突然多了3块钱的
Shure: The bank suddenly gained three coins
Lucia: 哈哈突然负债3个
Lucia: Haha, suddenly in debt by three coins
其他人：恭喜你
Others: Congrats!
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
其他人：我想说为什么说它错版
Others: I wanted to say, why is it a misprint?
Shure: 因为月亮和六便士
Shure: Because of "Moon and Sixpence"
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Shure: 哦谢飞竹觉得还挺对的哈哈哈
Shure: Oh, Xie Feizhu thinks it's pretty spot-on, haha
其他人： 月亮与六便士那么翻译问题吗我操
Others: Moon and Sixpence translation issues, what the heck?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 对
Shure: Yep
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Shure: 来吧来吧 3个币
Shure: Come on, come on, 3 coins
Shure: 从公家出啊
Shure: From the public funds
其他人：是这样的
Others: Exactly
其他人：他给的是吧
Others: He gave it, right?
Shure: 啊他给了是吧
Shure: Ah, he gave it, right?
Shure: 啊啊我以为他
Shure: Ah, ah, I thought he...
Alice: 别说出来
Alice: Don't say it
Alice: 你这不偷偷拿6个
Alice: You secretly took 6, didn't you?
Alice: 你给我
Alice: Give it to me
Shure: 他从他从世界银行走的
Shure: He got it from the World Bank
Shure: 我以为
Shure: I thought...
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay
Lucia: 怒赚6个
Shure: 我们下一位没了吧是吧
Shure: We don't have the next one, right?
Shure: 还有还有
Shure: Oh, we do
Shure: 小杜
Shure: Xiao Du
其他人： 我从学校带来一钥匙链 行胜一言钥匙链
Others: I brought a keychain from school, Xing Sheng Yi Yan keychain
其他人：好我就要拍了
Others: Okay, I'm going to take a picture
其他人：这个相当 这个在实验室跟了我半年里面积攒了各种我写代码的怨恨
其他人： 那个我大脑骂人的 语气我下班回家的开心还有那 在学校里面自由
Alice:啊哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Ahahahahaha
其他人：这上面有有怨灵哈哈哈
Others: There are grudges on it, hahaha
其他人： 怨灵
Others: Grudges
其他人：已经附魔了已经附魔了
Others: It's already enchanted, already enchanted
其他人：开过光的开过光的
Others: Blessed, blessed
其他人：你要再再再
Others: You have to...
其他人：一个是清华校徽
Others: One is the Tsinghua emblem
其他人：这边有清华大学
Others: This side says Tsinghua University
其他人：一个是二校门
Others: One is the second school gate
其他人：一个是那个日晷上的的那个行政语言
其他人：一共三一共三合一我觉得大家可以看一下
Shure: OK
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go
Shure: 那么我们现在开始一个币的起拍
Shure: Okay, now we start the bidding at one coin.
其他人：一个
Others: One.
Shure: 一个
Shure: One.
Shure: l同学出一个一个币一次
Shure: L has bid one coin, once.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Tasha: 我让他5分钟后到店
Tasha: I'll have him at the store in 5 minutes.
其他人：好大概多少分钟到家
Others: Okay, how many minutes until home?
Shure: 艾鲁艾鲁同学出了两个
Shure: Eru has bid two coins.
Shure: 两个币一次
Shure: 2个币两次
Shure: Two coins, twice.
其他人：这么大的东西才两个币
Others: Such a big item for only two coins?
其他人：我的天
Others: Oh my god.
其他人：这店里挺贵的呢
Others: This store is pretty expensive.
其他人：三个
Others: Three.
Shure: 3个3个币一次
Shure: Three coins, once.
Shure: 主办有没有想想想想要的3个币的啊
Shure: Anyone else interested in bidding three coins?
Alice: 可以可以
Alice: Yes, yes.
Alice: 给我掏钱吗
Alice: Are you paying for me?
Lucia: 超过了我的存款
Lucia: That's more than my savings.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 3个币一次
Shure: Three coins, once.
其他人：找世界银行给你贷款
Shure: 3个币两次
Shure: Three coins, twice.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 找世界银行给我贷款
其他人：贷点款
其他人：贷款是吧
Alice: 我可以贷4个币吗
Alice: Can I bid four coins?
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Shure: 我出4个
Shure: I bid four coins.
Shure: 4个币一次4个币两次了
Shure: Four coins, once. Four coins, twice.
其他人：5个老公给我买
Others: Five, honey, buy it for me.
Alice: 老公给我买
Alice: Honey, buy it for me.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh no.
Lucia: 5个5个5个5个5个5个5个5个5个5个5个5个
Lucia: Five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five.
Alice: 我我出的四个呀
Alice: I bid four coins.
Shure: 5个币一次
Shure: Five coins, once.
Alice: 4是我出的呀
Alice: I bid four coins.
Alice: 你压我干啥
Alice: Why are you outbidding me?
Shure: 5个币两次
Shure: Five coins, twice.
其他人：你有吗
Shure: 5个币3次
Shure: Five coins, three times.
Alice: 我没有
Alice: I don't have it.
Alice: 我不都贷款吗
Alice: Haven't I already taken out a loan?
Shure: 成交
Shure: Deal.
Tasha: 你就问他你就跟
Tasha: Just ask him, you just...
Tasha: 你就把那个码报给他
Tasha: Just give him that code.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 你就把这个码报给他
Tasha: Just give him this code.
其他人：我想我要不要哄抬物价来着
Tasha: 然后你说大概多长时间做好
Tasha: Then you ask how long it will take.
Tasha: 行了
Tasha: Got it.
其他人：没事儿你从我这10个币买走
Others: No worries, you can buy 10 coins from me.
Shure: 他人家就是那学校的哈哈哈
Shure: They are from that school, hahaha.
其他人：这才叫哄抬物价
其他人：哈哈哈二道贩子
Others: Hahaha, middleman.
其他人：我为什么会需要这种道具啊
Others: Why would I need this kind of prop?
其他人：还有，是不是没有人了
Shure: 还有还有奥
Shure: There's more, oh.
Shure: 什么any auction animal
Shure: What, any auction animal?
其他人：不卖了
Others: Not selling anymore.
Jake: 不卖了不卖了
Jake: Not selling, not selling.
Tasha: 不知道不知道
Tasha: I don't know, I don't know.
Tasha: 随便吧姐啊啊
Tasha: Whatever, sis, ah ah.
Jake: 卖卖卖卖卖一点
Shure: 哦哦哦
Shure: Oh, oh, oh.
Shure: 啊大家可以看到啊
Shure: Ah, everyone can see, ah.
Shure: 我们的大厨上来吧
Shure: Our chef is coming up.
Shure: 来来我们的我们的
Shure: Come on, our, our...
Tasha: 来给我拿着
Tasha: Come on, hold this for me.
Shure: 甜点甜点
Shure: Dessert, dessert.
Shure: king desert king还是desert king来着
Shure: King dessert, king or dessert king.
其他人： 我还要找骑手干嘛 呀
Others: Why do I still need to find a rider?
Shure: desert还是desert desert吧
Shure: Dessert or dessert, dessert then.
其他人：这个算拍卖里面吗
Others: Is this part of the auction?
其他人：啊这是拍
Others: Ah, this is an auction.
其他人： 是呀
Others: Yes.
其他人：刚才都
Others: Just now...
其他人：没饭吃了
其他人：花钱花的太早了
其他人：天呐要不要考虑这个
Others: Oh my god, should we consider this?
其他人：首先呢我们先征一下赔款
Others: First, let's collect some compensation.
其他人：就刚刚吃了
Others: Just ate it.
其他人：先把币拿上来
Others: First, bring the coins up.
其他人：你内个不是你内叫
Others: Isn't it that you... you called it...
其他人：你内叫什么销售
Others: You called it some kind of sales
Katrina: 我内个叫试吃
Katrina: I called it a taste test
其他人：对对对我我是试吃
Others: Yes, yes, I'm a taste tester
其他人：因为我是我是拍的
Others: Because I was the one filming
其他人：我是帮我姐拍的
Others: I was filming for my sister
其他人：所以我刚先试吃一下
Others: So I just tried it first
其他人：确保她的是正事
Others: To make sure it's legit
其他人：我已经试吃过
Others: I've already tasted it
其他人：她确认是正事
Others: She confirmed it's legit
其他人：然后这个水果就可以不算
Others: Then this fruit doesn't count
其他人：水果就不算了
Others: The fruit doesn't count
其他人：这个这个吃了
Others: This, this was eaten
其他人：刚刚我们可以先按整整个一个币啊
Others: Just now we can press the whole coin first
其他人：然后交上来
Others: And then submit it
其他人：先交上来
Others: Submit it first
其他人：刚刚谁吃了
Others: Who ate it just now?
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
其他人：调监控
其他人：强买强卖呀
其他人：我们可以先把下面的都我有15台监控
Others: We can first sell off the remaining ones, I have 15 cameras
其他人：大家我先把剩下卖完
Others: Everyone, let's sell the rest first
其他人：我们最后再来找这个人是是谁
Others: Then we'll find out who ate it last
其他人：首先我们可以先卖这个抹茶蛋挞
Others: First, we can sell this matcha tart
其他人：这个我吃了
Others: I ate this one
其他人：非常好吃
Others: It's really delicious
其他人：这个东西它的价值在于
Others: The value of this item is
其他人：抹茶粉非常的贵
Others: The matcha powder is very expensive
其他人：以至于
Others: So
其他人：撒抹茶粉和撒结的方法是不一样的
Others: The way to sprinkle matcha powder is different from others
其他人：呃它的味道的特点呢
Others: Uh, the unique taste of it
其他人：在于很像日本的什么
Others: Is very similar to Japanese
其他人：什么抹茶
Others: Some kind of matcha
其他人：反正就是非常的好吃
Others: Anyway, it's really delicious
其他人：那我们起拍价就按一共只有两个
Others: So our starting bid is, there are only two in total
Lucia: 谢谢
其他人：所以
Others: So
其他人：我们更希望它能成双成对的卖出去
Others: We hope to sell them as a pair
其他人：你要出去吗
其他人：所以我们起拍价就按一个蛋挞一个币
Others: So our starting bid is one tart for one coin
Lucia: 不是不是，我想喝口水
其他人：一个蛋挞一个币
其他人：抹茶比较贵最后一个蛋挞一个币
Others: Matcha is quite expensive, one tart for one coin
Shure: 一个蛋挞一个币
Shure: 我真好饿呀
Shure: I'm really hungry.
Shure: 你先给我来一个
Shure: Can you give me one first?
其他人：拍拍拍
Others: Clap, clap, clap.
Shure: 我出我出一个币
Shure: I'll give one coin.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
其他人：好一个币有没有啊
其他人：因为我们只有两个抹茶
Others: Because we only have two matcha.
其他人：剩下这些都比较多剩下这些都比较多
Others: The rest are quite a lot, the rest are quite a lot.
Shure: OK成交成交
Shure: OK, deal, deal.
Shure: 来吧给你一个币
Shure: Come on, here's one coin.
Shure: 我可以再
Shure: Can I get
Shure: 拿一个吗
Shure: another one?
其他人：再拿一个就是另外价钱
Others: Another one is a different price.
其他人：因为他现在已经只剩一个
Others: Because now there's only one left.
其他人：他就他等于要升级
Others: He has to upgrade.
其他人：你先你先拿一个
Others: You get one first.
Shure: OK我先拿一个
Shure: OK, I'll get one first.
其他人：你可以考虑拿第二个
其他人：这是蛋挞吗
Others: Is this an egg tart?
其他人：这带盘的一会再拍哦
Others: We'll take photos with the plate later.
路西：sorry
其他人：好那我们拍第二个
Others: Alright, let's take the second one.
其他人：因为他现在只剩一个
Others: Because now there's only one left.
其他人：所以我们可以附赠一个
Others: So we can give an extra one.
其他人：你举着抹茶蛋挞拍照的机会可以吧
Others: You can hold the matcha egg tart for the photo, right?
Lucia: 这怎么打不开了
Lucia: Why can't this be opened?
其他人：所以我们这个呢
Others: So this one
其他人：所以我这个
其他人：可以附赠一个举着抹茶蛋挞拍照
Others: Can come with holding the matcha egg tart for a photo.
其他人：所以呢按理来说价值两个币
其他人：但我们还有一个币起拍
Others: But we start with one coin.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
其他人：好，一个币还有没有别的了，一个币起拍
其他人：我来找骑手
Others: I'll find the rider.
其他人：那剩下的是骑手的责任
Others: Then it's the rider's responsibility.
其他人：不是你的责任
Lucia: 哪个？
其他人：好好还有吗
Others: Alright, is there any more?
其他人：坏了，没有只有一个币
其他人：快那你那你嗖的一下
Others: Quick, you, quickly
其他人：快没声了
Others: Hurry, it's getting quiet.
其他人：嗖嗖的吗
Others: Is it swooshing?
其他人：来上来你可以跟他拍个照片啊
Others: Come on, you can take a picture with him.
其他人：我要和他合照
Others: I want to take a picture with him.
其他人：对你可以你可以啊
Others: Yes, you can, you can.
其他人：你卖的是合照钱不是商品哦
Others: You're selling photo opportunities, not products.
其他人：商品和合照钱
Others: Products and photo money.
Shure: 你这有兜吗
Shure: Do you have pockets?
其他人：你可以跟他合照
Others: You can take a picture with him.
其他人：和这架子合照
Others: Take a picture with this stand.
其他人：或者你想单独举着它也可以
Others: Or if you want, you can hold it alone.
Lucia: 哎我把我手机扔哪了
Lucia: Hey, where did I throw my phone?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahahahaha
Lucia: 啊，在这边
其他人：你为什么卖的是人家的合照
Others: Why are you selling other people's photos?
其他人：我们是友好合作
Others: We're friendly collaborators.
其他人：一会给你冠名权
其他人：我一会可以白送你一个
其他人：好好好哈哈
Others: Okay, okay, haha.
Tasha: 哈有种这个明星甜品合照的感觉
Tasha: Haha, it feels like taking a photo with a celebrity dessert.
其他人：我们接下来要拍哪个
其他人：拍这个，这个是巧克力粉
其他人：比较适合巧克力的重度爱好者
其他人：虽然虽然我我就
Others: Although, although I...
Jake:和主厨握手的机会
Jake: A chance to shake hands with the chef.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
其他人：我就很喜欢吃这个所以它就剩了一个
Others: I just love eating this so there's only one left.
其他人：这个里面它的优势在于它有这个
Others: Its advantage lies in this...
Lucia: 怎么是所以啊哈哈
Lucia: Why is it "so" haha?
其他人：这个巧克力豆比草莓就味道就不一样
Others: The chocolate chips taste different from strawberries.
其他人：他自己黑下几个
Others: He blacked out a few himself.
其他人：非常契合这个巧克力粉的设计理念
Others: Perfectly fits the chocolate powder design concept.
其他人：因为考虑到他也是孤品呢
Others: Considering it's a one-of-a-kind.
其他人：就可以和主厨握一下手
Others: You get to shake hands with the chef.
其他人：这个握手的价钱呢
Others: The price for the handshake...
其他人：另算呃但是呢
Others: Is separate, but...
其他人：只要你握手我们就附赠合照的机会
其他人：对吧
Others: Right?
其他人：所以所以起拍价是一个币然后握手呢
Others: So the starting bid is one coin, and the handshake...
其他人：握一个币
Others: One coin for a handshake.
其他人：我们当然我也可以单独拍这个
其他人：我们也可以先不握手
Others: We can also choose not to shake hands first.
其他人：因为后面握手机会还要很高
Others: Because there will be plenty of chances to shake hands later.
其他人：然后我们起拍价是一个币
其他人：别拍了不要拍了
Others: Stop filming, don't film anymore.
其他人：一个币
Others: One coin.
其他人：一个币真的没有吗
Others: Is there really no one offering one coin?
Shure: 一个币一次
Shure: One coin, once.
其他人：快流拍了
其他人：这个时候我们应该有一些内部人员出点钱
Shure: 我出我出我出一个币
Shure: I'll bid, I'll bid one coin.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Alright.
其他人：还要点什么烤串
Others: Do you want some kebabs?
其他人：那如果没有的话那就
Others: If not, then...
其他人：那就又又拍给你了
Others: Then it's yours again.
其他人：你给我一个币就可以了
Others: You just need to give me one coin.
其他人：那你那你要和主厨握手啊
Others: But you, you need to shake hands with the chef.
Shure: 我一会再握吧
Shure: I'll shake hands later.
其他人：一会再过那就是两个币哈哈
Others: If you shake hands later, that's two coins, hahaha.
其他人：握手可以拍照
Others: You can take a photo while shaking hands.
其他人：你还可以选择你握手
Others: You can also choose to shake hands.
其他人：那那你可以把这个拿出来
Others: Then you can take this out.
Shure: 谢谢谢谢
Shure: Thank you, thank you.
其他人：多么有戏剧性的一种片
Others: Such a dramatic scene.
其他人：呃剩下的我们可以先拍这个麻薯
Others: Uh, the rest, we can start filming this mochi.
其他人：这个麻薯我们是做盒卖的哦
Others: We sell this mochi in boxes, oh.
其他人：这个我们就一个
Others: This one is just one.
其他人：一盒一个币
Others: One box, one coin.
Katrina: 哈哈哦可以
Katrina: Haha, oh okay.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
其他人：因为这个麻薯属于限量制作
Others: Because this mochi is made in limited quantities.
其他人：但是蛋挞它属于特别
Others: But the egg tarts are special.
其他人：制作而且蛋挞都是孤品
Others: Each egg tart is unique.
其他人：麻薯它现在还不是孤品
Others: The mochi is not unique yet.
其他人：我们是市场调节的
Others: We're adjusting according to the market.
其他人：好吧这个我们第一个人买的是可以选的
其他人：第一个人买可以选这个和这个就后面
Others: The first buyer can choose between this and this, then after...
其他人：比如说如果第一个人选了
Others: For example, if the first person picks...
其他人：他后面就只有巧克力了
Others: Then there's only chocolate left for the next.
Alice: 那个蛋挞应该这样
Alice: The egg tart should be like this.
Alice: 我的臀部翘的可以顶起一瓶汽水
Alice: My butt is so perky it can hold up a soda bottle.
其他人：对有两个口味
Others: Yes, there are two flavors.
其他人：第一个买的人是你选的
Others: The first one to buy gets to choose.
其他人：来一个币
Others: One coin please.
其他人：好，一个币有没有加价的
其他人：都可以选口味
Others: You can choose the flavor.
其他人：这个口味
Others: This flavor.
其他人：是是是是是巧克力和
Others: Yes, yes, it's chocolate and...
Katrina: 巧克力吗
Katrina: Chocolate?
其他人：巧克力和啥呀
Others: Chocolate and what?
其他人：啊
Others: Huh?
Tasha: 豆粉吧黄豆粉
Tasha: Soybean powder, maybe.
其他人：好好OK OK
Others: Alright, alright, okay, okay.
其他人：豆乳豆乳
Others: Soy milk.
Alice: 我快没story了
Alice: I'm running out of stories.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Alice:只有5个g了
Alice: Only 5G left.
其他人：两个好
Others: Two, okay.
其他人：两个币可以选口味
Others: Two coins can choose the flavor.
其他人：这位先生
Others: This gentleman.
其他人：用两个币争取到选口味的机会
Others: Use two coins to get the chance to choose a flavor.
其他人：还有没有了
Others: Any more?
Lucia: 纸嗯哎我记得这里放了一包啊
Lucia: Paper, hmm, I remember I put a pack here.
其他人：好
Others: Okay.
其他人：so那你可以来选一个口味
Others: So, you can choose a flavor.
Lucia: 那是应该有一包
Lucia: There should be a pack.
Lucia: 可能用完了
Lucia: Maybe it's used up.
其他人：就是一个两个巧克力
Others: It's one or two chocolates.
其他人：你要巧克力
Others: You want chocolate?
其他人：好呀那我们现在拍卖还可以选口味
Others: Alright, now we can choose the flavor in the auction.
其他人：还可以选口味非常的宝贵
Others: You can still choose the flavor, it's very valuable.
其他人：因为你后面不拍的话就买不到
Others: Because if you don't bid, you won't get it.
其他人：就没有办法选口味
Others: You won't be able to choose the flavor.
其他人：那我们依旧是一个币起拍
Others: We still start at one coin.
其他人：但是我们历史参考价都是两个币
Others: But our historical reference price is two coins.
其他人：历史参考价是两个币
其他人：好有没有出价的
Others: Alright, any bids?
其他人：来一个币
Others: One coin.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
其他人：好两个币还有没有了
Others: Alright, two coins, any more?
其他人：哈哈哈还有没有
Others: Hahaha, is there any more?
其他人：好那就两个币
Others: Okay, then two coins.
其他人：很明显上面那个在市场上不受欢迎
Others: It's obvious the one above is not popular in the market.
其他人：完了上面这个在市场上不受欢
Others: Yeah, the one above is not popular in the market.
其他人：迎那那
Others: Yeah, yeah.
其他人：剩下感觉不好卖
Others: The remaining ones don't seem easy to sell.
Alice: 还有这个
Alice: There's also this one.
其他人：鉴于你的这个麻薯的
其他人：剩余的麻薯在市场上活动
Others: The remaining mochi in the market...
其他人：我们可以可以等待时间检验一下
Others: We can wait and see how it performs over time.
其他人：我们现在先拍这个纸杯蛋糕
Others: For now, let's take pictures of these cupcakes.
其他人：这是一个新品
Others: This is a new product.
Lucia: 我决定偷走一个
Lucia: I'm going to steal one.
Lucia: 谢谢你哈哈哈谢谢你
Lucia: Thank you, hahaha, thank you.
其他人：这个纸杯蛋糕
Others: These cupcakes...
其他人：吃吧吃吧，拿走吧拿走吧
其他人：它的优势在于它附赠一个纸杯
Others: Their advantage is that they come with a cup.
其他人：给大家吃，给大家吃
其他人：这是一个非常环保的纸杯
Others: This is a very eco-friendly cup.
其他人：而且它这上面的草莓呢
Others: And the strawberries on top...
Lucia: 你光不是
Lucia: You just...
Lucia: 我刚咬了一个
Lucia: I just bit one.
其他人：个数比较多
Others: There are quite a few.
Lucia: 你快问问大家吃不吃
Lucia: Ask if anyone wants to eat.
其他人：至少都是有两半草莓
Others: At least there are two halves of strawberries.
其他人：我们刚刚卖过的这个抹茶蛋挞
Others: The matcha tarts we just sold...
Lucia: 是吗买下的同学请大家吃
其他人： 上面只有半片草莓
Others: Only had half a strawberry on top.
其他人：呃同样
Others: Uh, similarly...
Lucia: 先放这吧
Lucia: Let's put this down first.
Lucia: 一会想吃的时候可以吃
Lucia: We can eat it later if we want.
其他人：这个纸杯蛋糕是一个币一个
Others: These cupcakes are one coin each.
Lucia: 我蘸一下
Lucia: I'll dip it.
Lucia: 但是两个币三个
Lucia: But three for two coins.
其他人：但是两个币三个
Others: But three for two coins.
其他人：所以我们就可以任意的价格起拍
其他人：是一个币
其他人：买一个还是两个币
Others: Buy one or two coins.
其他人：买3个你可以选，好
其他人：快没人出价要流拍了
其他人：来一个币
Others: One coin.
其他人：一个币来一个币
Others: One coin, one coin.
其他人：那你要要一个吗
Other: Do you want one?
其他人：啊好你们是一个一个卖的吗
Other: Oh, so you sell them one by one?
其他人：我也可以两个币三个卖
Other: I can sell two for three coins.
其他人：一个币一个两个币三个
Other: One coin for one, two coins for three.
Lucia: 你俩到底谁在以读乱回你
Lucia: 你买不买
Lucia: Are you buying or not?
其他人：你买不买两个币就是三个
Other: Are you buying or not? Two coins for three.
其他人：对我没有两个币
Other: I don't have two coins.
Lucia: 我去拿个纸吧
Lucia: I'll go get a paper.
其他人：你没有两个币
Other: You don't have two coins.
其他人：那你可以向世界银行贷一个
Other: Then you can borrow one from the World Bank.
Lucia: 我去拿包纸
Lucia: I'll go get a pack of paper.
Lucia: 哦咱们的纸居然快用完了
Lucia: Oh, we're almost out of paper.
Lucia: 嗯嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
其他人：你要给我两个币
Other: You need to give me two coins.
Tasha: 你看过了
Tasha: Did you see it?
Tasha: 你不知道是月亮与六便士是啥
Tasha: Don't you know what "The Moon and Sixpence" is?
其他人：好的 世界银行拿一个
Other: Alright, get one from the World Bank.
其他人：你是银行大股东
Other: You're a major shareholder of the bank.
其他人：反正已经反正已经贷了，多贷点
其他人：觉得我们可以走一下
Other: I think we can move on.
其他人：迅速销售
Other: Quick sale.
其他人：那改这东西没法卖呀
Other: This thing can't be sold like this.
其他人：这东西卖的不能让他连盆直接端走呀
Other: You can't just take the whole pot directly.
其他人：那那我们可以一会再卖
Other: We can sell it later.
其他人：我们可以先中场休息一下
Other: We can take a break first.
Lucia: 这个产品是
Lucia: This product is...
Lucia: 我已经蹲了很长时间了
Lucia: I've been waiting a long time for it.
Lucia: 等待吃他
Lucia: Waiting to eat it.
其他人：开始直接room two吧
Other: Start directly with room two.
Lucia: 我今天怎么回事
Lucia: What's wrong with me today?
Lucia: 怎么老碰掉各种各样的东西
Lucia: Why do I keep knocking things over?
Tasha: 嗯还有四五十分钟
Tasha: Hmm, about fifty more minutes.
Tasha: 一个小时
Tasha: One hour.
Lucia: 哎你粘了一个
Lucia: Hey, you stuck something.
Lucia: 那个小眼睛
Lucia: That little eye.
其他人：对我这个耳钉掉了然后不知道在哪就用这个代替
Other: Yeah, my earring fell off and I didn't know where it was, so I used this instead.
其他人：我操
Other: Damn.
其他人：我收你20%佣金不过分吧
Other: Charging you 20% commission isn't too much, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:来我们跳一下
Jake: Come on, let's jump
Jake:跳一下之后我们就导眼镜爽
Jake: After we jump, we'll enjoy the glasses
Katrina: OK
Lucia: 让我再去检查一下我的那个有没有掉
Lucia: Let me check if mine fell off
Lucia: 这两个是谁
Lucia: Whose are these two?
Lucia: 这个可能是宇轩的吧
Lucia: This might be Yuxuan's
Lucia: 我感觉不是
Lucia: I don't think so
其他人：我说这是谁买的呢
Others: I was wondering who bought this
Lucia: 哦那我不知道
Lucia: Oh, I don't know
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow
Shure: 那我的那个闺房十十个
Shure: I have ten of those in my boudoir
Katrina: 放过gas吧
Katrina: Let the gas go
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Tasha: 嗯从一楼开始吧从二楼开始吧
Tasha: Hmm, let's start from the first floor, or maybe the second floor
Shure: 从二楼吧从二楼吧来吧
Shure: Let's start from the second floor, come on
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 等一下他又掉了
Lucia: Wait, it fell off again
Lucia: 呵他又掉了
Lucia: Haha, it fell off again
Lucia: 他又掉了
Lucia: It fell off again
Lucia: 别掉了谢谢
Lucia: Don't fall off, thanks
Lucia: 别掉了你可千万别再掉了
Lucia: Don't fall off, please don't fall off again
Tasha: 是吗哇
Tasha: Really? Wow
Katrina: 你的真的很漂亮
Katrina: Yours is really pretty
Lucia: 哇哇好可爱
Lucia: Wow, wow, so cute
Shure: 哇
Shure: Wow
Katrina: 绝了好吗
Katrina: Absolutely amazing
Katrina: 来介绍一下
Katrina: Come, introduce it
Lucia: 哇太可爱了吧
Lucia: Wow, so cute
Katrina: 这就是我梦想中的房间
Katrina: This is my dream room
Lucia: 这就是我梦想中的房
Lucia: This is my dream room
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Katrina: 我拍了给我妈看
Katrina: I'll take a picture for my mom
Lucia: 线条小狗
Lucia: The lines on the puppy
Katrina: 让我妈看
Katrina: Show it to my mom
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 好漂亮
Lucia: So beautiful
Jake:那我们下一个课还是好像介绍一下
Jake: So, our next class, we should probably introduce it.
Jake:不用好像也不行
Jake: We can't really skip the introduction.
Lucia: 好像到我这边了是吧
Lucia: I guess it's my turn, right?
Katrina: 介绍
Katrina: Introduce.
Lucia: 能把这个小小马
Lucia: Can you move this little pony
Lucia: 还是小狗稍微扳一下吗
Lucia: or maybe the puppy a bit?
Lucia: 要不然大家可能不方便过去哎
Lucia: Otherwise, it might be hard for everyone to get through.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Lucia: 希望他希望我墙上粘的这些胶没有掉
Lucia: I hope the adhesive on the wall isn't falling off.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 啊没掉
Lucia: Oh, it's not.
Lucia: 大家快看
Lucia: Everyone, look!
Lucia: 否则他一会就掉了
Lucia: Otherwise, it'll fall off soon.
Lucia: 然后这是一个地中海风格的房间
Lucia: And this is a Mediterranean style room.
Lucia: 卧槽哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Whoa, hahaha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Shure: 我本来没有那么好奇你
Shure: I wasn't that curious about you at first.
Shure: 你这喊完之后我就想看了你知道吗
Shure: But after you shouted, I really wanted to see it, you know?
Shure: 哦哦可以可以
Shure: Oh, oh, alright, alright.
Jake:哇
Jake: Wow.
Jake:好可以我突然觉得很开心
Jake: Okay, I suddenly feel really happy.
Shure: 看着很开心
Shure: It looks really nice.
Lucia: 哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, yeah.
Lucia: 就是它的整体主色调是蓝色和白色
Lucia: The main color scheme is blue and white.
Lucia: 对就是就是
Lucia: Yeah, it's like...
Lucia: 模仿了就是地中海地区
Lucia: It's modeled after the Mediterranean area.
Lucia: 就是可能
Lucia: Like, maybe...
Lucia: 主要是希腊那边
Lucia: Mainly Greece.
Lucia: 最常见的建筑风格的颜色
Lucia: The most common architectural color styles.
Katrina: 好像参观海洋馆啊
Katrina: Feels like visiting an aquarium.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 是有一点
Lucia: It does a bit.
Lucia: 然后是用了墙贴渔网
Lucia: Then we used wall stickers of fishing nets.
Lucia: 然后用欧根纱模仿了一个海浪的形状
Lucia: And used organza to mimic the shape of waves.
Lucia: 对然后就随时都可以看到小鱼
Lucia: Yeah, so you can always see little fish.
Jake:空调开了鱼还会飞
Jake: With the AC on, the fish will fly.
Lucia: 哦你说的很有道理
Lucia: Oh, you have a point.
Lucia: 要不然现在开开试试
Lucia: Why don't we try turning it on?
Lucia: 哈哈不行
Lucia: Haha, no we can't.
Lucia: 这个因为我用的是那个
Lucia: Well, it's because I'm using that...
Lucia: 就是那种粘性比较弱的纸
Lucia: You know, the kind of paper with weak adhesive.
Lucia: 害怕在墙上留印子嘛
Lucia: I'm afraid it'll leave marks on the wall.
Lucia: 所以如果风太大可能就会掉
Lucia: So if the wind is too strong, it might fall off.
Lucia: 但是我觉得领导这个提议非常不错
Lucia: But I think the leader's suggestion is great.
Lucia: 下次对对对
Lucia: Next time, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 回家我就把它改成强力胶
Lucia: When I get home, I'll switch to strong glue.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
其他人：能和你房间合影吗
Others: Can we take a picture with your room?
Lucia: 可以啊
Lucia: Sure.
Lucia: 也也可以
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, that's fine.
Lucia: 不过这个房间其实稍微有一点点乱的
Lucia: But the room is actually a bit messy.
Lucia: 还是
Lucia: Still...
Lucia: 那我在这站一下好了
Lucia: I'll just stand here then.
其他人：要坐床上吗
Others: Should you sit on the bed?
Lucia: 呃没事就不坐了吧
Lucia: Uh, no, it's fine, let's not sit.
Lucia: 坐了这床可能更乱
Lucia: Sitting will make the bed even messier.
其他人：如果你站着就会挡到你后面的墙画
Others: If you stand, you'll block the wall art behind you.
Lucia: 哦没事
Lucia: Oh, it's fine.
Lucia: 因为这个墙不是这床我
Lucia: Because this wall, this bed...
Lucia: 本来是想用床单铺一下
Lucia: I originally wanted to cover it with a bedspread.
Lucia: 但是没铺整齐这样吧
Lucia: But it didn't turn out neat, so...
其他人：321
Others: 3, 2, 1...
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 下接下来他们楼下的同学还有
Lucia: Next, the students downstairs, and...
其他人：真不错小房间我很喜欢
Others: Really nice, I like this little room.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Lucia: 我是赶工了一上午赶出来的
Lucia: I rushed to finish it this morning.
Lucia: 真的本来是昨天就要装修好的
Lucia: Honestly, it was supposed to be done yesterday.
Alice: 好那可以看我的了
Alice: Alright, can you check out mine now?
Alice: 我的在边边角角
Alice: Mine is in the corner.
Alice: 你们来进吧
Alice: Come on in.
其他人：哇
Others: Wow.
Alice: 别太夸张 家人
Alice: Don't exaggerate, guys.
Lucia: 哇好好看
Lucia: Wow, it looks great.
Lucia: 没掉
Lucia: It didn't fall.
Lucia: 反正我看到的部分都没掉
Lucia: At least the part I see didn't fall.
Lucia: 这样特别好好好看哇
Lucia: It's really nice, looks so good, wow.
其他人：哇
Others: Wow.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
其他人：所以这个耳钉是故意漏出来的吗
Others: So, was this earring intentionally left out?
其他人：呃发壳卧槽
Others: Uh, wow, damn!
其他人：牛逼不是
Others: Amazing, isn't it?
其他人：叹为观止
Others: Truly impressive.
其他人：好香啊嗯
Others: It smells so good.
Lucia: 你这个香薰好好闻
Lucia: Your fragrance is really nice.
Katrina: 我也要看我也要看
Katrina: I want to see, I want to see too!
Katrina: 我的房间非常简约
Katrina: My room is very minimalist.
Katrina: 就是理工科
Katrina: Just like a science lab.
Katrina: 你看没电脑就摆那
Katrina: See, there's no computer, just placed there.
Katrina: 然后倒头就睡的那种
Katrina: And then you can just crash and sleep.
Lucia: 好看好看
Lucia: It looks great!
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哎怎么有股桂花香的味道
Katrina: Hey, why does it smell like osmanthus?
其他人：看看看看修硕的房间
Others: Let's check out Shure's room.
Jake:啊看看修硕的房间
Jake: Yeah, let's see Shure's room.
Lucia: 来看看修硕的房间
Lucia: Come on, let's see Shure's room.
其他人：唉唉唉唉
Others: Hey, hey, hey!
其他人：人呢
Others: Where is he?
其他人：听说了比较朴素在里面
Others: I heard it's pretty simple inside.
Jake:修硕在里面
Jake: Shure is inside.
Lucia: 起床了
Lucia: Wake up!
Shure: 等一下
Shure: Just a moment.
Lucia: 咋回事啊
Lucia: What's going on?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈被子还没有叠
Lucia: Hahaha, the bed isn't even made.
Shure: 被子还没有叠
Shure: The bed isn't made.
Lucia: 他可能不是
Lucia: Maybe he's not...
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 他最重要的装修步骤应该就是叠杯子
Lucia: His most important decoration step must be making the bed.
其他人：好的现在现场装修
Others: Alright, now live decorating.
其他人：对对对他已经没有机会叠被子了
Others: Yeah, yeah, he doesn't even have time to make the bed.
其他人：他已经没有时间叠被子
Others: He doesn't have time to make the bed.
Lucia: 靖康的参观了吗
Lucia: Have you seen Jingkang's room?
其他人：金康现在还不被允许参观
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 哎人呢
Lucia: Hey, where is he?
Lucia: 哦他也在收拾行吧
Lucia: Oh, he's also tidying up.
Lucia: 哎呦他的房间是最早成型的
Lucia: Wow, his room was the first to be ready.
Lucia: 不用收拾
Lucia: No need to tidy up.
Shure: 好就是
Shure: Alright, just...
Lucia: 好好好生活简约是吧
Lucia: Okay, okay, simple living, right?
其他人：简约是吧
Others: Simple living, right?
Shure: 朴朴素素就是真
Shure: Plain and simple is the truth.
Lucia: 好好
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Shure: 这个被子是叠过的啊大家哈哈哈
Shure: This quilt is folded, everyone, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这被子叠的好呀叠的好啊
Lucia: Hahaha, this quilt is folded well, really well.
Shure: 叠的好吧
Shure: Folded well, right?
Tasha: 来吧这个大这个大
Tasha: Come on, this one is big, this one is big.
Lucia: 这个这个他他在里面吗
Lucia: This one, this one, is he inside?
Katrina: 我我比他多一点颜色哈哈哈
Katrina: I have a bit more color than him, hahaha.
Tasha: 嗯他说可以开门了他说可以开门了
Tasha: Hmm, he said we can open the door now, he said we can open the door now.
Lucia: 啊也在叠被子中
Lucia: Ah, also folding the quilt.
Katrina: 一眼看出理工科
Katrina: You can tell they're an engineering major at a glance.
其他人：哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 赛博朋克吗风
Lucia: Cyberpunk style?
其他人：这个很好啊
Others: This is really nice.
其他人：这竟然是个麻将桌
Others: This is actually a mahjong table.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这个
Lucia: Hahaha, this is...
Jake:大家可以想象的到
Jake: Everyone can imagine...
Jake:我们平时的工作状态
Jake: Our usual work state.
Jake:我们平时一只手要控制八台电脑
Jake: We usually have to control eight computers with one hand.
Katrina: 八爪鱼
Katrina: Like an octopus.
Lucia: 你那个一只手控制8台电脑是有什
Lucia: What's the joke behind controlling eight computers with one hand?
Lucia: 么梗在里面吗
Lucia: Is there a joke in there?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你确定你不是一只手关掉8台电脑
Lucia: Are you sure you're not just shutting down eight computers with one hand?
Lucia: 哈哈哈是这么控制啊
Lucia: Hahaha, is that how you control them?
Lucia: 哈哈你再说一遍
Lucia: Hahaha, say it again.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:这个可能在这个位置的时候穿过的
Jake: This might happen when we're in this position.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
其他人：哈哈就一只手碰掉总电源呗
Others: Hahaha, just turn off the main power with one hand.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Lucia: 然后他紧急把我叫出来帮他关硬盘
Lucia: Then he urgently called me out to help him shut down the hard drives.
Jake:哈哈有一次我不小心碰到这个键
Jake: Hahaha, once I accidentally hit this key.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Jake:让他乌鸦进来把所有的都关掉
Jake: Let the raven come in and shut everything down.
Jake:然后我再松手离开
Jake: And then I let go and walk away.
Lucia: 我觉得这个故事特别精彩
Lucia: I think this story is really exciting.
Lucia: 一定要讲给大家都听听
Lucia: You definitely need to tell everyone.
Lucia: 今天终于有机会了
Lucia: Finally got the chance today.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 他就一直摁着不敢松吗
Katrina: He kept pressing it and didn't dare to let go?
Lucia: 对他一直摁着
Lucia: Yeah, he kept pressing it.
其他人：松了就完蛋了
Others: If he let go, it would be over.
Lucia: 摁到所有的硬盘都弹出之后他才敢挂
Lucia: He didn't dare to hang up until all the hard drives were ejected.
Katrina: 解放军打仗踩到地雷
Katrina: Like a soldier stepping on a landmine.
Jake:是是是哈哈
Jake: Yeah, exactly, haha.
Katrina: 不客气
Katrina: You're welcome.
Katrina: 你俩也是这个房间的时尚单品
Katrina: You two are also the fashion items of this room.
Lucia: 笑死我了
Lucia: You're killing me.
Katrina: 蓬头垢面的
Katrina: Looking all disheveled.
Jake:好那刚好各位把眼镜给放到这来了
Jake: Alright, just put your glasses here, everyone.
Lucia: 啊对对对
Lucia: Ah, yes, yes.
Jake:直接放到自己
Jake: Just put it on yourself.
Jake:可能大家还没有
Jake: Maybe everyone hasn't yet.
Lucia: 他这有那个什么
Lucia: He has that thing.
Jake:大家可以找到自己的电脑
Jake: Everyone can find their own computer.
Jake: 然后放到这个
Jake: Then put it here.
Tasha: 什么东西
Tasha: What thing?
Shure: 我以为你忘取了
Shure: I thought you forgot to get it.
Katrina: 我是哪个
Katrina: Which one is mine?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 这个是你的
Tasha: This one is yours.
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Hold on.
Katrina: 还没那边还放了一条乱七八糟的
Katrina: Not yet, there's still a mess over there.
Katrina: 那你俩只能睡这么大
Katrina: You two can only sleep this much.
Lucia: 我们都还没停止
Lucia: We haven't stopped yet.
Jake:最起码有4个人要睡
Jake: At least four people need to sleep.
其他人：这还不够吧
Others: Isn't that not enough?
Katrina: 我可以我自己就可以横着睡
Katrina: I can, I can sleep horizontally by myself.
Katrina: 竖着睡斜着睡都行
Katrina: Vertical, diagonal, any way is fine.
Jake: 对我平常都是这么睡的
Jake: Yeah, I usually sleep like that.
其他人：足够了足够了
Others: It's enough, it's enough.
Lucia: 等一下我的VPN好
Lucia: Wait a second, my VPN is working.
Lucia: 好像又掉了
Lucia: It seems to have dropped again.
Katrina: 为什么你的vpn一一直掉
Katrina: Why does your VPN keep dropping?
Lucia: 没掉就很奇怪
Lucia: It's weird that it didn't disconnect.
Lucia: 我经常点开他都会掉线
Lucia: Whenever I click on it, it often disconnects.
Jake:修硕把眼镜交上来把关掉交上来
Jake: Shure, hand over the glasses. Turn it off and hand them over.
Lucia: 他这现在这个这个这个状态
Lucia: His current, uh, this, this, this status.
Lucia: 我能不能complete
Lucia: Can I complete it?
Jake:呃我看一下我看一下有点修硕的简介
Katrina: 修硕的简介笑死
Katrina: Shure's profile is hilarious.
Lucia: 他变成呃现在呃对呃呃状态还正常
Lucia: He turned into, uh, now, uh, yeah, uh, his status is normal.
Lucia: 他刚才这不见了
Lucia: He just disappeared.
Lucia: 但又加载出来了
Lucia: But then it loaded again.
Jake:OK好可以的
Jake: Okay, good, it's fine.